nous allons vous proposer une croisière
sur la Seine et nous allons d'abord nous
diriger vers l'écluse d'Andrésy
bienvenue à bord de la célèbre vedette
fluviale le Tyrano embarquement immédiat
pour 1h30 de promenade au fil de l'eau
en compagnie de Catherine guide
conférencière on descend le fleuve
jusqu'à l'écluse de Andrésy et le
barrage on explique ce qu'est la
batellerie et puis les principes de la
batellerie ça c'est le début des bateaux
à moteur mais en fait c'était moteur à
vapeur et donc c'est en 1821 qu'ils sont
apparus sur la scène et donc le principe
c'est que ils avaient une cheminée pour
pouvoir faire partir la vapeur et ben
pour passer sous les ponts la cheminée
était amovible une balade accompagnée
d'anecdotes sur ce port fluvial chargé
d'histoire
sur le chemin de halage pour tirer cette
ce nouveau bateau qui va amener
l'obélisque jusqu'à Paris
[Musique]
à 17h jusqu'au 11 septembre